[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
danse avec lerman spécial tombe bien
entendu la danse si l'on est d'avoir les
remarques pour arriver dans un instant
[Applaudissements]
partenaire christine kelly
et
[Musique]
à
fais gaffe aux jeunes
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bouillant benjamin castaldi et sa
partenaire pas dériver nez
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé que c'était une merde sans
nom
toulouse
vous
ah ouais
on apprécie oblige
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
paris
à
ça a été la tuer j'ai perdu un salon
ouvert le tango à mykonos et quand on
s'appelle non tanguay ah oui
ah oui quand même ah ils ont bossé
ils sont votés
c'est ce match
adam se bouffer
malgré ce qu'on fait
ah oui
c'est bien cette campagne par cette
mascarade
est pourri ça me pourrit ça pas mal
dégueulasse non dégueulasse et ça est
astronome médard cas
[Musique]